[Music]
you don't have to be an intellectual to
recognize how much season 8 sucked
especially in comparison to the previous
seasons even casual fans recognized it
which the official ratings clearly show
this channel grew infamous for
criticizing the show in season 8
episode after episode for bad writing
and bad continuity and the general lack
of logic
it's not a secret that the show had a
potential to become the best show ever
which still is to me even with the
horrible final season
just because it had the absolute perfect
6 seasons
yeah season 7 was bad as well in my
opinion but season 8 was a disaster
even actors scoring money by excellent
acting skills
cannot hide how disappointing they are
with season 8. the story was rushed
character arcs destroyed there should
have been 10 seasons
the entire season 8 and the first part
of season 9 should have been the long
night
the war against the night king the
second part of season 9 and the entire
season 10 about dany's descent into
madness and war against cersei
that's what hbo wanted as well they
tried to convince them to do 10 seasons
but were lucky enough to even get this
much from dnd because they originally
wanted only 7 seasons
in truth hbo did not even get a full
season they only got 3 extra episodes
out of david and dan
their planned final season was supposed
to have 10 episodes but when hbo
convinced them to make
8 seasons they reduced number of
episodes from 10 to 7 for season 7
and had only 6 for season 8. anyways in
this video we are going to talk about
every single error in season 8 episode
1. before we dive into the series i just
want to highlight that
all the criticism is directed towards
the showrunners and not towards actors
in the whole crew that did their best
with the horrible scripts they've got
actors and everyone involved in game of
thrones except for d d deserve a
standing ovation for their hard work
over the years
with that said let's get into it the
season 8 premiere starts with a nice
callback and parallels to season 1
premiere
which is quickly ruined by tyrion's
awful joke you should consider yourself
lucky
at least your balls won't freeze off you
take great defensive tour jokes but love
telling uni jokes why is that
because i have balls and you don't
[Music]
thought i was wise but i wasn't when you
don't have a capability to continue
tyrion's brilliant arc from the earlier
seasons
dropping his iq considerably ever since
you passed the book material this is
what you get
arya's look at dragons gave me hope that
this season might have some story
continuity
because she seemed so happy to see them
arya has always admired dragons
and especially the targaryen queen who
wrote them we learned that early on in
season 2 episode 7
when arya reveals to time in lannister
how she adores aegon to conquer her
sister
reign is sami zhenya with the latter
being her heroine
i guess arya kind of forgot her
character was supposed to like danny
here boy melt it down and add it to the
others
sansa's look at dragons when they fly
over vinderfeld gives me such a little
finger wind
she sees something so powerful and
doesn't see a way not to bend her knee
to such power
and it bothers her which we clearly see
when she greets dany
still senses that she's a slow learner
but she learns then how come didn't she
learn from littlefinger to give fake
smiles and pretend she likes dany
a reaction which should have been
natural in the first place because the
dragon queen has come to save your home
and your people
when john and bran reunited then bran
replied to jon's you're a man with
almost i thought that reunion could have
been done better
but at that point i was really looking
forward to how bran's story will play
out
i was excited that his story will
finally be somewhat exciting
as beside the tower of joy his visions
and holder moment
bran's whole story was rather boring in
fact it was so boring that the
showrunners did not even include bran in
the entirety of season 5.
yeah that's right and if you didn't
notice i don't blame you because the boy
was so boring
bran missed out the entire fifth season
i thought this
nate had all the potential to redeem him
from being this boring weird guy
to an interesting three-eyed raven
filled with visions and all the war game
we could witness
at the end all bran did was nothing we
did not see one vision in season 8
and the only thing bran worked was a few
ravens
and apparently that's the best story
i remember before season 8 aired javi
all thought bran's powers would be
crucial against the night king
after all he did high pass up by saying
he needs to see better before the night
king arrives
also don't forget that tower of joy
vision from the past in which he calls
out to his father ned who hears him
well all of that turned out to be of no
significance at all it turned out to be
nothing
they really did subvert our expectations
north nerds being unhappy with dany's
arrival at winterfell makes no sense
especially knowing they found out from
branded the night king has a dragon in
his army now
and has broken the wall and already
started his conquest over the north
instead of their smug faces and worrying
about what dragons eat
and worrying about who has what title
they should have cheered at the arrival
of dany
her two dragons and her huge armies i'm
glad jon snow shot
sansa and all the petty northern lords
by saying that without dany and her army
and her dragons
they would not stand a chance although i
don't like his statement i had a choice
keep my crown or protect the north i
chose the north because that's a lie
after viserion was shot down and when
they were on the boat going to king's
landing with a kidnapped white
dany gave him her word that she will
march her army's north
and together they will destroy the night
king john then said thank you dany
on which she replied that she doesn't
remember who called her that last time
perhaps her unpleasant brother viserys
zombie john replied
all right not danny how about my queen
and ben the knee
not literally cause he was injured but
it was pretty much it
so when john says i had a choice keep my
crown or protect the north
implying that dany would not come if he
did not bend the knee is not true
i guess dnd kind of forgot about the
entire boat scene and about jon snow not
being able to lie
the season 8 is rushed and full of
errors
anyways tyrion then also tries to
explain to these petty northern lords
that without jon snow
and his successful travel south to
convince the dragon queen to help the
north
they would all die this is followed by
possibly the most stupid question in the
show
which is sansa's question may i ask how
are we meant to feed the greatest army
the world has ever seen
while i ensured our stores would last
through winter i did not account for the
threaky and solid and two full-grown
dragons
while the dragons eat anyway really
sense that that's your concern
will there be enough food until the
night king attacks you tomorrow evening
and what the dragon seat
conversation with sansa comes up sorry
i'm getting
really annoyed with sons but he kind of
like
you know she's like why are you going
south and he's like well because we're
all going to die otherwise
and she's like well you can't do it just
it drives me mad
it tries too mad that she keeps coming
up with
these nonsensical suggestions i didn't
realize this annoyed me so much
sorry it's like a jon snow therapy
session
someone should sit here like a small
child and explain to her that not only
does wienerfell stand no chance against
the night king without dany but they
would not even have the weapons that are
able to kill the night king's army that
dany provided from dragonstone
then he literally has nothing to gain
from this allegiance with the north
she has seen the night king she knows
she will lose far more of her own men
than the north could ever provide her
and still she decides to save the north
danny should have pulled the sensa moves
sensa di donaria in season 7
about how without her the nord did not
stand a chance in a fight
and she should be on her knees thanking
her at least sansa does recognize in
episode 2 that instead of being rude
she should have thanked her as soon as
she arrived he loves you you know that
that bothers you men do stupid things
for women
they're easily manipulated now i'm here
half a world away fighting john's war
alongside him
tell me who manipulated him
i should have thanked you the moment you
arrived
that was a mistake but then in episode 3
and all the remaining episodes she is
back to her power hungry
and ungrateful attitude total [ __ ]
though
why her
you know she loves your brother that
doesn't mean she'll be a good queen
you seem determined to dislike her
tyrion says if anyone survives the world
to come
will have jon snow to thank he did risk
his life to show us the threat is real
thanks to his courage we have brought
the greatest army the world has ever
seen
we have brought two large full-grown
dragons oh boy did you thank him after
we all survived
not only did he save all of westeros
because he convinced danny to alive with
the north and defeat the night king
but at the end he also killed dany to
once again save estros from dany the
madqueen the [ __ ]
writers made her mad in the span of one
episode who intended to liberate all the
westeros by burning down everything and
everyone
they especially tyrion thanked him
really good at the end
not even mentioning his name at the
great council when electing the king
banishing him to the wall to make things
even worse the council was literally
made up of 90
of people who are good with jon most
being his friends and family
most of whom knew john was the rightful
king when the question of the potential
king came in nobody mentioned his name
i'll go hard on that when we come to
that episode anyways back to the season
8 premiere
next we have a scene in which we see
tons and tons of dragonglass that they
mined
and brought from dragonstone to winner
fell which is the only thing capable of
killing the night king's army
beside a few valyrian steel swords and
fire what was the purpose of showing all
of these dragon blasts when in episode 3
we see that the entire dothraki cavalry
who are on the first line of defense
or should i say offense don't even have
dragonless weapons
and therefore one hundred thousand of
them would not be able to kill even one
white
lucky for them melisandre showed up
unexpected out of nowhere
and said there are arcs on fire best
writing ever
lady of winterfell
has a nice ring to it so does hand of
the queen
depending on the queen i suppose is she
really saying that the queen who instead
of going for the iron throne and
remaining
south came to help her and the north is
not a good queen
what sansa and tyrion's conversation had
some good parts with the two discussing
the last time they saw each other
especially when sansa says joffrey's
wedding had its moments and both smiled
it really hurts to see how the
showrunners made tyrion go from one of
the smartest people in the realm
to a complete fool who believes cersei
will send army north and sansa here
mocks him for that not for the first
time
they really thought it would be okay
with sensa who spent only a few years
around cersei
understanding her character and motives
better than tyrion cersei's brother who
spent most of his life with her
yeah right tyrion and his plans being so
idiotic in recent times is not a
testament how tyrion's character is
stupid because it's not
tyrion is one of the smartest people in
this world but it's rather that show
runners were not smart enough to do his
character after the book material ran
out
how drastically they reduced tyrion's iq
is still beyond me
every single of darion's plans in
seasons 7 and 8 were so bad and
devastating for dany
that at one point before being sent the
leaks i was convinced tyrion was a
traitor working for cersei
i even made a few videos about it john
arya reunion was actually alright for
some part
in my opinion it could have been done
better but compared to everything else
it was alright hugging the first part of
the conversation was done just fine
but then arya goes on to stay on
stanza's side instead of supporting jon
who is obviously right about them
needing dany also detaria's now already
infamous line sansa is the smartest
person i've ever met
is such a punch to the face to all of us
get me wrong i'm okay with sansa being
smart she's had years and years of
learning to play the game of thrones
learning from some of the best including
cersei and littlefinger
but with the one who knows the game
really act like that towards dany
can you see someone really politically
smart act like that towards their allies
who came to save them
anyway zarya saying sansa is the
smartest person she's ever met is plain
stupid
especially when you remember she met and
spent a good amount of time with none
other than mighty timing lannister
then again arya is not very good with
words which we'll learn later when she
says for dany i know a killer when i see
one
right after dany burned down the entire
king's landing killing 1 million people
good call arya so yeah are you saying
for sansa to be the smartest person
she's ever met makes no sense
not only because zarya definitely met
people smarter than
sansa but also because there was nothing
sensa displayed in season 7 or 8 that
would lead arya to say that
sense almost fell for littlefinger's
game in season 7.
that's right it was not sensa
manipulating him it was once again her
being manipulated
during the entire season until bran told
her behind the scenes what's
littlefinger really about
and what he did this was confirmed by an
actor who plays brent stark as well as
by the showrunners
so there's that also if jones how did
you sneak up on me was meant to
foreshadow arya sneaking up on the night
king two episodes later in the same
place
that's not smart for shadowing because
here jon is alone so it's explainable
and logical that a year or two of
training to become a stealthy assassin
would result with her being able to
sneak up on a person who is alone
but her sneaking up on the night king
who is surrounded by all the white
walkers and his entire army of the dead
yeah that's a bs and by the way as you
can see there's literally nothing arya
could have used to come close to the
night king without being spotted
nor something to use to jump on him the
way she did
their reunion ends vittoria saying to
jon something along the line
don't forget you're maya and sansa's
family with jon's face being like
what at a time i thought bran told arya
and sansa about jon's parentage
and that's why arya says this but no we
see them learn that later from brain
instead of learning it from jon which
made me so angry
so her saying this to jon snow here
makes no sense
down south things are not going great
either euron tells yara his ship silence
is full of mutes
thank god they are still holding
continuity in some parts of the story
oh never mind later they kind of forgot
they had no tongues when they yelled and
shouted
iren's complete character is just a joke
i honestly feel bad for the actor who
was so pumped to play yearn because he's
a big fan of the books
and expected his character to be like in
the books one of the most evil and
badass characters
telling news reporters how his character
is going to make both joffrey and ramsay
look like little babies
that was before he got the scripts poor
guy
sorry probably probably too much
information
okay that's too many errors for one
video we'll have to stop right here
the part 2 for season 8 episode 1 errors
is coming tomorrow
you